when mankind is consumed by darkness and
the land falls into chaos
the archdemon of the abyss shall rise
from the earth
they come rushing here in a desperate
attempt to survive
both beast and man have more in common
than they think
brace yourself
[Music]
be careful
[Music]
it can't be
and these wandering flames
shall feed the beast
and return to darkness
the story ends
another begins
[Music]
wandering flames
[Music]
i see you found your home
[Music]
remember what you're fighting for
from
here it goes
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
the year is 5012 a.d
machine life forms have overwhelmed the
planet causing the collapse of
civilization and forcing humans to take
refuge on the moon
now with an android squad called jorja
the humans are prepared to stand against
these machine life form invaders
[Music]
a battle android 2b
and a scanner android 9s
are two key members of this squad
machine life forms in conflict with
androids
what will come of this bloodless battle
[Music]
this version of the award-winning
near-automata comes with previously
released content including additional
modes and costumes
new costumes exclusive to the nintendo
switch version will also be available at
launch
reclaim earth in near automata the end
of your edition launching on the
nintendo switch system october 6th
pre-orders begin today on nintendo eshop
mario and the rabbids blast off for a
galactic adventure in the latest mario
plus rabbids game
space is in a universe of trouble when
other otherworldly enemies suddenly
appear
their goal
take the energy possessed by sparks
these mysterious creatures
now our heroes must set out to save them
a new adventure of epic proportions
awaits
[Music]
you'll initiate a turn-based battle when
you encounter an enemy
[Music]
before we begin here's something you
ought to know
you can freely move around the
battlefield as much as you'd like within
your character's range before using
their weapon
pretty neat huh
let's start with mario
three enemies are in the way so let's
dash into one of them
[Music]
now select rabbit rosalina and have her
dash into another
next rabid luigi
one more dash and now disruptor time
by using a dash first then the weapon
three enemies were wiped out with that
his turn is over
back to mario
let's take out the other two
pew pew
that concludes his turn
last but not least rabid rosalina team
up with an ally and jump
get positioned then finish off with the
kaboomer
okay our turn's over
and now the enemy attacks be sure to
take cover and you might be safe
if you don't it won't be pretty
all right we've got the floor again
[Music]
dash toward the bomb
and if you chuck it over
boom
that'll do it
the key to victory is how you assemble
your team and navigate around the
battlefield
wait is that bowser and he's joining the
team
mario plus rabbids sparks of hope
rockets onto the nintendo switch system
october 20th pre-orders begin today on
nintendo eshop
check out ubisoft's special showcase
tomorrow for more details about mario
plus rabbids sparks of
hope sonic's latest action adventure
kicks off on the vibrant star fall
islands home to a mysterious
civilization
here you can freely dash through a vast
open zone taking full advantage of
sonic's speedy skills
[Music]
lock on and attack enemies standing in
your way
chain together attacks to trigger combos
and rack up damage
with good timing you can even deflect
enemy attacks
acquire skills to bolster sonic's
arsenal of moves
you can also enter a special zone called
cyberspace
take on challenges at supersonic speeds
and grab keys to progress
what awaits sonic on these strange
islands
sonic frontiers dashes onto nintendo
switch this holiday
[Music]
mission
start
[Music]
coming at ya
i'm morgana reigning ace of the phantom
thieves apart
and today i'm bringing along an ultra
top secret video
[Music]
i hope you're ready
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
yep persona 5 royal will launch nintendo
switch october 21st
and that's not all
let's get the ball rolling cons eddie
[Music]
nice baton pass morgana
okay everyone check this out
[Music]
bear leave it persona 4 golden and
persona 3 portable are also coming
[Music]
keep your eyes peeled for more persona
on nintendo switch
you